we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p i think that
this caller misunderstands the
definition of the word fact let's listen
together hey listen huge fan of the show
but I hate the Patriots and I wanna let
you know they're gonna get smacked by
the Steelers my feelers are going to
work them whoop them so I'm just like I
know you like to deal with facts right
so I'm telling you facts the Patriots
are getting stomped fat Steelers are
going to win at the fact on my words the
Terrible Towel will strike in Foxborough
yeah listen I am rooting for the New
England Patriots of course as I believe
you are Rachel yeah and as I believe you
are pat of course okay aside from that
though to say that a prediction about
the outcome of a game that hasn't
happened is a fact goes against the
definition of a fact by its very nature
predicting an outcome for a game in the
future is not a fact it's the fact that
the caller predicted that but it's not a
fact to say the Patriots will lose
that's not a fact but there's a common
usage of the word fact colloquially
colloquialism in a very slang way
amongst many young men that I've
witnessed I guess I just seen a trend
with men you've never seen women did you
do this I not as much as I cement so for
instance I've seen a lot of my male
friends who will comment on the
appearance of a girl yeah and say oh
that girl is dope facts oh right what is
an opinion exactly but it has a it's
changed its that its meaning for it for
the younger crowd it's pat one of the
young men you to witness do that I have
you have multiple occasions okay well
anyway listen I will be watching I'm
very very excited about this game and
the winner will go to the Super Bowl
what was super bowl 52 I don't you want
51 it's hard to keep track at this point
on the bonus show today google maps may
soon show you how difficult it is to
park near your destination there's a
startup that wants to restore your youth
with blood transfusions although they
don't actually tell you
that it will work and a controversial
band is taking on the Supreme Court in a
trademark case all of those stories and
more on the bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up and get
instant access